اذا وليد استمعنا قبل قليل الا نتنياهو
يتحدث عن اتخاذ عده قرارات وخطوات ردا على
هذه العمليه هل هناك ملامح اوليه لما يمكن
ان تكون عليه هذه الخطوات
شديد جدا وحاله كبيره من الانزعاج نتنياهو
قال بان في الاجتماع الذي انهاهه في مقر
القياده القطريه للشرطه في القدس الشرقيه
تم اقرار سلسله من الاجراءات الفوريه التي
بدا بتنفيذها لكن هذه الاجراءات سيتم
تطويرها وستمر بقرارات من الطاقه الوزاري
الامني المصغر الذي سيستمع غدا مساءا هذا
ما قاله لا هو لم يوضح بالضبط عندما سئل
واي اجراءات هذه قال ستسمعون عنها لاحقا
الاجراءات الفوريه الذي تحدث عنها هي
تعزيزات امنيه واسعه عمليات مداهمه
واعتقال عائله المجتمع بانه منفذ العمليه
من منطقه حي الطور او ضاحيه الطور في
القدس الشرقيه المحتله هناك مداهمات على
نطاق واسع هو يرى بان هذه الاجراءات تاتي
في اطار بيضات الامنيه همم الوقائيه
المستعجله من وجهه نظره لكن يبدو ان هناك
خطوات اخرى ينتظروا وصول وزير الدفاع
واجتماع الطاقه مع الوزاري غدا مساءا من
اجل ان يتم همم اقرارها على نطاق واسع
نشير هنا الى ان نتنياه الان مطالب ولو من
مما سمعناه من الاسرائيليين الغاضبين
الذين استقبلوه واستقبله معه ومن قبله
وزير الامن القومي الذين قالوا لهم بانكم
همم الان هذه فتره ولايتكم انتم هذا يحدث
في ظل ولايتكم فهو سيحاول ان يثبت انه
اقوى همم قوي مثل ما كان يروج دائما لذلك
متوقع ان تكون هناك اجراءات اسرائيليه او
اعمال انتقاميه اسرائيليه وهمم ليس
مستبعدا ان يتم افلات ميليشيات من
المستوطنين ايضا وهؤلاء عباره عن جيش في
الضفه الغربيه ومعروف ان بين كبير وامث هم
يحذرون من هذه الميليشيات لذلك متوقع ان
يكون هناك اجراءات عن نطاق واسع لكن
السؤال يبقى ما هي الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
التي سيتحدثون عنها وهل سيجرؤون على اتخاذ
اجراءات قبل وصول وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
من شانها ان تؤثر على زيارته المقرره ان
يبداها يوم الاثنين همم اللافته في الامر
كله هو سيحاوله اما ان يبداوا بعمليات
مداهمه وهدم سلسله من المنازل الفلسطينيه
لمنفذين السابقين بما فيهم
المجتمع بتنفيذ عمليه الليله في يعقوب
وايضا في سلسله اخرى من المداهمات قد تكون
لمناطق مثل نابلس وجنين من جديد خاصه
وانهم يتدلعون بان همم
علينا الاسود في نابلس وكتيبه جنين ايضا
في مخيم الجنين هم يعدون سمعتهن هكذا يرون
ثانيا هناك دعوات ايضا تزايدت وان تؤكد
وايه الاجهزه الامنيه الاسرائيليه بان منى
المعلومات التي لديها عن منفذ هذه العمليه
بانه منتصفهم بالذئاب المنفرده اي انه لا
ينتمي لفصيل بعينه او فصيله فلسطينيه
معروف وانما شاب خرج وقام بهذه العمليه
بمحض- ارادته دين توجيههم لاحد الا ان
هناك دعوات ايضا الى ان يشمل الانتقام او
الاجراءات الانتقاميه ان تشمل ايضا انقطاع
غزه وان لا تقتصر فقط على الضفه الغربيه
فضلا عن هذا كله واضح بانهم سيستهدفون
ايضا السلطه الفلسطينيه على نحو اكثر من
ما كانوا يستخدم
مزيدا من الاموال التي تصلها ومحاصرتها
وربما مصادره ايضا او الحد من حركه
عناصرها خاصه وان هذه التوليفه اليمنيه
حاليا لديها مشروع هو تحويل الضفه الغربيه
الى ادارات وليس ان تبقى كواحده واحده وكل
المنطقه لها ادارتها بمعنى انهاء هذا
الوجود للسلطه الفلسطينيه او اضعافه
اضعافها اكثر مما هي ضعيفه حتى الان في
جميع الاحوال الاجراءات الفوريه التي تحدث
عنها نتنياهو سبق وذكرناها وهي الاشتياحات
وتعزيزات بقوات الاحتلال وشرطته في كافه
ارجاء القدس المحتله وايضا اغلاق معظم
الحواجز او كافه الحواجز بين القدس وشمالي
والجنوبي الضفه الغربيه
ولكن ماذا عن ردت فعل المعارضه
الاسرائيليه المعارضه لهذه الحكومه كيف
تتعامل مع الاوضاع وكيف تتعامل ايضا مع
رده الفعل المحتمله للحكومه
[موسيقى]
عادهم يستقيمون مع موقف الغضب في الشارع
الاسرائيلي ولا يستطيعون مواجهته هذه
المعارضه او المعارضه اخرى في اسرائيل لكن
حتى الان لم يصدر عن المعارضه مواقفه
مناهضه ولا انما هم يعلنون عن غضبهم
وهناك بعض المحللين او السياسيين السابقين
المحسوبين على المعارضه سواء اليمنيه او
من الوسط او من اليسار الذين يرون بان
سياسه التصعيد التي تمارسها هذه الحكومه
والتهديدات العنصريه والانتقاميه انما هي
ايضا سبب لما وصل اليه هذا الامر النقطه
الثانيه هناك من بات يتهموه الشرطه
ووزيرها وغيرهم بان لديهم فشل وتقصير واضح
ويتسبب بمثل هذه العمليه لانهم لم يتخذوا
الاجراءات اللازمه كما يجب واكتفوا باطلاق
التصريحات على نطاق واسع همم نضيف في هذا
الثيا لله بان تطورات الاوضاع ميدانيه اذا
تواصلت قد هذا يتسبب بان هناك من المعارضه
مثل غاز وغيره قد يلجا الى الانضمام الى
هذه الحكومه بدريعه ان هناك خطر امني كبير
وانه وجوده داخل الحكومه سيساعد في حمايه
امن اسرائيل وغيرها العقليه الامنيه في
اسرائيل هي العقليه صاحبه القرار اكثر من
غيره لكن مع وجود التوليفه الجديده هناك
العقليه الثوراتيه الدينيه التوراتيه ال-
ال- العقائديه وهي ايضا مؤثره خاصه وانها
لا تشتغل بطريقه الاعتباطيه وانما لديها
دراستها لديها استراتيجيتها ولديها
مشاريعها التي كشفوا عنها وكشفت عنها
مصادرهم بعضها اسربوها مثل الهجوم
الاستراتيجي الاستيطاني الذي يشمل العمل
على وضع مخططات للثمانيه عشر الف وحده
سكنيه في انحاء مختلفه من الضفه فضلا عن
الموجود بالاضافه الى محاوله منع
الفلسطينيين من العيش والتوسع والبناء في
المنطقه سي المنطقه جيم وهي المنطقه التي
تمتد على نحو ثلثي الضفه الغربيه وهي تحت
السيطره الكامله للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بموجب اتفاقيات اوسلو
والموضوع الاخر ان اسرائيل والحكومه
الحاليه همم سمواتش الذي وزير الماليه
حاليا لكنه وهو الصهيوني دينيه
طالب ووافق له نتنيه على ان يتم نقل
الاداره المدنيه من الحكم العسكري الى
سيطرته الكامله والحرس الحدود الذي كان
مكلفا تحت قياده الشرطه في القدس وقياده
الجيش في الضفه الغربيه ان تنقل صلاحيات
عليه وادارته الى
وهم يريدون التحكم بادق التفاصيل المتعلقه
بحيات الانسان الفلسطيني لانه مشروعهم كما
قلنا هو تقسيم الضفه الغربيه وليس ابقائها
وحده واحده وانما توزيعها الى طوائف
وقبائل وادارات ولكل منطقه ادارتها
والتعامل معها حسب واقعها ان كانت هادئه
العمل معها بسياسه الجزر وان كانت غير
هادئه التعامل معها بالسياسه العصا
الغليظه هذا فضلا عما يبيتوه للقدس
وتحديدا للمسجد الاقصى